We're going to run campaigns, be field directors.
We're going to be affiliated with the arts.
We're going to seek public office.
We're going to be journalists.
wanted us to be.
No longer are we just going to be doctors,
lawyers and engineers as our parents always
service.
And as we mature, you'll see us kind of spread
throughout various fields, including public
We're a fairly young population in America.
But it's also, no in truth, we are coming
and we are going to be engaged like any other
American, and you're going to respect our
voice like you respect anybody else's.
And the hashtag that I used was #TheMuslimsAreComing.
And that's in jest, right?
So I recently hosted the Michigan Muslim Capitol
Day in Lansing.
That's why I want them to take the lead.
When it comes to our generation, we're afraid
to say what's on our mind, but they're not.
Our community is people that are in their
30s, in their 20s.
But a lot of our parents' generation now,
they trust us to lead.
Our community is no longer just one voice.
I've literally lived in this house on Miller
since I was born.
I was born and raised here.
I'm just as American as anyone else.
Although I'm Muslim, I'm American.
doing.
people with President Donald Trump as their
president, [to] see themselves in what I'm
people, young people, who are worried about
this moment, who have to grow up as young
I like to think that in doing this, I have
the opportunity to show a number of other
And I pray a certain way, and I'm fully comfortable
in being that guy.
I have had a beard since I was 19.
And, so, I am Abdul.
And that's the only person I can govern as.
I'm not interested in governing as anybody
else but me.
being Athiest, being whatever they [are],
LGBTQ, whatever it is — I don’t ever want
Have you ever thought about changing your
name?
anybody to feel like they have to hide it.
I don’t want anybody, whatever their faith,
being Jewish, being Muslim, being Catholic,
I’m embracing being a Detroiter.
I’m embracing being Arab-American.
I’m embracing being Muslimah.
I’m embracing being Palestinian.
They're seeing me.
The candidates we spoke to aren't shying away
from being Muslim-American.
I think it’s about time you give us a chance.”
I think it’s time for us come and fix the
gun crisis, fix the education system.
You had your chance.
Clear out the room.
We’re waiting for that time where it’s
like, “You know what boys?
So, I think with women, we’re much more
analytical.
And look what we got.
You know?
gonna run for president.”
You know, we tend to wait when we’re needed,
where men kind of get up and say, “I’m
You know, women tend to be reactionary.
engaged.
also a lot more Muslim-American women, who
are not just running, but who are politically
You know, we've heard there's a lot more Muslim-Americans
running, but it really feels like there's
office.
She was a state representative in Michigan
for six years and now she's running for national
One of those women is Tlaib.
community.
of amazing powerful Muslim women who have
spearheaded a lot of the changes within our
We keep saying Muslim-Americans, but I think
it's also very important to note the amount
What would you say is the reason why there's
Muslim-Americans running?
The high school we went to was literally named,
well, not named, like far-right extremists
used to call it “Hezbollah High.”
When 9/11 happened, that was kind of like
a wake-up call for all of us.
So that's what triggered a lot of us to step
up in that way.
The election of Trump for a lot of us was
a reminder of that.
And that was nowhere that we ever wanted to
be again.
Obviously, a lot of our rights were taken
away as a community.
None of us ever felt insecure in this nation,
or in this country as a community, until 9/11.
Zainab, was [his] campaign manager, so she
basically ran the helm.
Ghida, who's run a lot of campaigns.
But Abdullah Hammoud is the one we're most
proud of.
Are you all in politics like inherently, or
how does it work?
We usually get together [and] talk politics.
After Iftar no one has anything to do.
During Ramadan, it's when all our schedules
collide.
Why do you guys meet?
Why are we here?
about politics [and] have some tea.
We're at Hussein Dabajeh's house, and some
young Muslim-Americans are gathering to talk
Right now we're in Dearborn.
other regardless of any religion, identity,
ethnicity or the color of their skin.
I'll take you to Alter Road, where our mosque
neighbors our churches.
I'll take you to our middle and elementary
schools, where our youth play amongst each
I invite any and everyone that would like
to, to come down to the city of Dearborn and
And that all you have to do is reach out to
ask questions.
To anybody that shares those sentiments, I'd
say that willful ignorance is radical.
right now, and that's largely because many
of us have stood out of the arena.
What would your message be to people who share
Patrick's kind of sentiments?
I think division is the tool of small people,
and there are a lot of small people in leadership
targeted their sights on me.
I knew that when I jumped into this, there
were going to be a lot of hateful people who
el-Sayed was part of a Muslim plot to start
a civilization jihad.
In April, a video by a Republican candidate
for governor, Patrick Colbeck, surfaced, claiming
And incidents targeting mosques increased
10-fold from 2009 to 2016.
Hate crimes against Muslims have spiked in
the last two years.
And that’s why it’s important that I'm
out here door-knocking because that direct
human contact is important.
The faith alone, Islam, is so misunderstood
by so many.
Michigan House had never ever worked with
a Muslimah or American-Muslim.
But I also see such opportunity, because 109
of my colleagues on the House floor of the
So, you’re going to get that backlash.
Write that name down because we don’t want
to send Rashida to Lansing to bomb it.”
“Vote for Santa Claus.
You know?
I also got, “Oh, don’t vote for Rashida”
at a polling location.
you're fighting just for today.
That this, you know, utopia where everyone
is treated equally, is a distance away, but
That you're not there yet.
You just have to tell yourself that the work
must continue.
How does this make you feel?
and slammed the door back in my face.
running for state representative,” he said,
“I'm disgusted that you're my neighbor,”
My own neighbor, I recall, when I knocked
his door and said, “Abdullah Hammoud, I'm
But being a Muslim in politics comes with
its challenges.
state.
I’m not running to be the first Muslim anything,
I'm running to be a great governor for my
the responsibility to be engaged and to raise
voices matters a lot.
And I think for the Muslim-American community
in particular, there is so much to lose that
I was really frustrated with governance at
both the local level and the state level.
Yeah, I mean, it was sorta the icing on the
cake for me.
Did Trump having anything to do with you wanting
to run?
Michigan is also a swing state that some blame
for putting Donald Trump in the White House.
Many of them are here in Michigan.
At least 90 Muslim-American candidates are
running for office nationwide.
House — more Muslim-Americans are running
for office than ever before.
Despite a surge in hate crimes and all the
anti-Muslim rhetoric coming from the White
You're removable, I'm not.”
are my rights.
But at the same time, on the flip end, that's
also empowered folks to say, “No, these
who's there that doesn't really see me as
an equal American?”
Folks are saying, “Are my rights protected
in the same way now that we have a president
It's unfortunate that Trump is in office,
but he might have been a catalyst to create
this awakening.
And that was when I realized I can’t be
outside of the ring anymore.
And my heart sank.
And as we, you know, kind of mature within
the American culture, I think we'll just continue
My son walks in the room and says, “Mama,
don’t worry.
If anybody asks me, I will lie and tell them
I’m not Muslim."
to rise.